l'histoire on a fait un archétype de
femmes d'influencé ce buste de diane de
poitiers trouve naturellement sa place
dans l'exposition
tout comme ses courtisanes de la haute
société japonaise figuraient sur des
estampes de l'ère edo
l'influencé est envisagée au sens large
grâce à des représentations de femmes de
pouvoir ainsi qu'à toutes sortes
d'objets alors une arme à feu féminine
on s'y attend pas parce qu'on associe
souvent la brutalité et la violence à
l'homme est en fait les femmes posséder
aussi des armes simplement pour mettre
dans le sac à main on a une petite arme
du début du 19e siècle ou encore on peut
trouver une francisque une arme franche
ou mérovingienne qui a été découvert
dans la tente d'une femme donc
probablement une une guerrière les 27
oeuvres et objets exposés proviennent
des réserves du musée où dorment 48
mille pièces et ont été sélectionnés par
des habitants et habitantes de dreux
lors de plusieurs réunions en
partenariat avec les maisons de quartier
un dispositif inédit sur des écrans les
commissaires d'exposition amateurs
expliquent leur choix
cette volonté première était de
rapprocher le musée de ses habitants et
les habitants du musée on a vraiment
l'ambition que ça devienne leur maison
ça l'est déjà mais que ça le soit encore
plus on a choisi cette installation
dans un premier temps pour ce qu'elle
offre en terme d'expérience et de
partage avec les commissaires
d'exposition elle met vraiment les
habitants de la ville au coeur de l'expo
l'exposition est visible jusqu'à fin
2022 le musée prépare déjà d'autres
groupes de travail avec des citoyens
commissaire
[Musique]